[Music]
i would love to hear from each of you
how you came to this project and what
attracted you to the stories and the
characters who are in this story so if
we can start with you rebecca that would
be great
yes you can start with me um
i read the book 13 years ago
at a moment when i was
speaking more honestly openly
acceptingly
about the mystery and ambiguity around
my family on my mother's side pardon me
i don't mean to stare but i think i know
you
claire
lots of people pass all the time it's
easy for a negro to pass for white i'm
not sure it'd be so simple for a white
person pass for color
this is my husband jambalu does he no
do you dislike negroes mr bellew no no
not at all
i hate them
we're all of us passing for something or
other
[Music]
aren't we
my mother you know i grew up in england
with my american mother she's from
detroit michigan but there was always a
sort of
mystery around
her racial identity
you have to put it into perspective i
was you know growing up in english fancy
schools where people
you know post-english people arrive in
their range rovers and et cetera et
cetera and people would look at my
mother and say things like wow isn't she
so exotic looking
right yeah it gives you some kind of
feeling yeah it gives you some kind of
feeling and i when i asked her about it
or i would say something about it or it
would come up like you know for example
when we were watching imitation of life
together for example
um
she would say yeah yeah it's possible
that we're black
it's possible that we're native american
i don't really know
someone handed me this book because
increasingly i found myself
in situations specifically in america
actually for whatever for what it's
worth it's worth quite a lot
um
sitting in rooms where people made
assumptions about
what i am based on what they're seeing
and i found myself increasingly not
being comfortable with that and sort of
sticking out my hand and awkwardly
honestly
awkwardly saying
i think i might be mixed race
and someone handed me this book and said
this is going to help with what you're
trying to articulate
and i looked at the book and i thought
passing what does that mean
i honestly didn't have the word
and when i read it it was instant
context for me it was instant
understanding it was
it was one of those moments when you go
of course this explains why there's this
mystery this denial this secrecy around
this asp this thing in my family because
any history of passing in a family is
necessarily hidden it's necessarily
erased a family protects they
close in and they lock down and they
don't talk about it that's what
my mother inherited from her father
it gave me the book gave me
a context and a framework from which to
address my own racial identity
it also gave me
a context and a framework to think about
identity full stop
period sorry as you would say
it
the book is extraordinary
i couldn't stop myself adapting it the
moment i finished reading it like i shut
the book and i
opened the laptop and i started writing
a screenplay
all the
big ideas that you see in the movie
black and white 4-3 complicated
soundscape in interior
all these
sort of sensual quiet moments the
silence of the movie those were all
ideas that i had on my first read of the
book
and
went into the first draft of the
screenplay which i wrote 10 days after
reading the book
yeah it wasn't very good
don't give me too much credit it was a
first draft it was the first run
but it had the big ideas in it and i
think the big ideas frankly frightened
me i thought this is too much no i can't
make this for my first film it's too
formally ambitious it's too big this is
bigger than me this is bigger than
everything that i could possibly do
so it sat in a drawer for six years and
then after that
six years i spent trying to think about
writing other screenplays trying to
direct other films because i've always
wanted to be a director ps um
i didn't have as much clarity of vision
as i did with passing so i went back to
it and i thought
yeah why not actually what am i doing
just make this you know how to make it
so i started showing it to people and
then
then it was seven years of trying to
convince people to give me the money
um and everyone's saying no i mean
literally everyone's saying no
everyone's saying this is unmakeable
you'll never get this made
maybe you will if you make it in color
maybe you will if you change certain
things if you take away some of the
ambiguity or you shift some of the roles
i mean
it it was
every step of the way was very difficult
is what i'm saying but it was it was
interesting because the feedback i would
always get would be this sort of there
would be a cognitive dissonance about
what i was hearing because people would
say wow what an extraordinary story
what an extraordinary isn't it amazing
how universal it is and how it explains
all of our struggle to define ourselves
and i must go and read the book and i'd
say yeah great so you're going to give
me the money
no
[Laughter]
and then i found nina young bon jovi and
forest whitaker who were two
extraordinary producers whose
literal mo is to do the things that
everyone says no to
and
they did not say no to me about anything
they let me make it exactly how i wanted
to make it
i i want to come back to that sorry that
was a big answer
no no it was great to set the contacts
and to really help us frame and
understand what it took to get it up and
we we all know that this is a struggle
to make films um but sometimes you know
really hearing the details are important
um tessa what about you
i can't follow that up
um
[Music]
ruth and i made a very silly discovery
today we've been doing press all day and
behind us there was the graphic that was
passing and accidentally my elbow was in
front of it in the frame and it just
said assing and i was like well that's a
different film
um
i told you i had nothing
eloquent to contribute after that
beautiful answer it was a good segue
though
someone back there like sassy
thank you so much everyone for being
here it's it's uh it's really mean so
much to to
be having conversations with audiences
here and i know it's still
as evidenced by all the mask wearing
it's still um you know tricky to get
places so thank you
um
what was the question the question was
around
why we're here yes yes um
i read this uh quote today this nina
simone i was like scrolling on instagram
and um and i didn't hear i had never
heard this quote before and i'll butcher
it so i won't say the whole thing but
she said she constantly has to
re-examine her identity to herself
her intentions
her convictions
why she does the things that she does
and i think something really compelling
about doing this project was
a chance to re-examine my own identity
and also to make something that
hopefully asks audiences to re-examine
theirs
because of course there is this layer
this idea of passing uh in a racial
context
but i think there's also this idea of
all the ways in which we pass which
irene says to her friend hugh
um and
i think so often we're put into boxes uh
and and oftentimes by ourselves right to
fit squarely into them we're afraid to
sort of spill over
um and so i thought that examination was
really incredible and then the chance to
i've just admired rebecca's work for so
long as an actor um and
not surprisingly you said today
something that you
feel like you always approach your work
as an actor sort of like a director
would in a way
you're hyper aware of the macro of a
story not just the micro and i can see
that in your work and i knew that taking
on a character like irene both to do
justice hopefully to nella larson's
beautiful work and also
if you've read the book it's the
interiority it's so dense you know what
she's thinking and feeling she doesn't
always have language to express it so
that challenge and i couldn't imagine
doing it with someone um
anyone else just because you could do
that as an actor and so i thought
selfishly she'll help me do it um
and and then also that you had real skin
in the game you know meant a lot that
you're re-examining your identity inside
of writing this piece and making it and
then the chance to work i knew that ruth
was going to play claire and so
important that irene
finds claire absolutely beguiling and i
do find ruth nega absolutely beguiling
in everything she's ever done and i knew
she would be in this
and then
an embarrassment of riches because andre
holland came to play and and he's
someone that i wanted to
get to do more work with we got to play
together in selma but not have a lot
and one time we sat and read shakespeare
together and he is he's so tremendous so
it's just been a dream to get to work on
this
[Applause]
um
[Music]
well
myself and rebecca had been
sort of bumping into each other on the
um
the old press circuit
and um
she had been talking to me about
something she was working on and then we
eventually met in new york and
um
she talked about directing this
adaptation that she had done of the book
and i love the book
and
she talked about it like how i felt
about it and
you know i saw a
mirror in her how i felt about this book
viscerally how
you know you know when you read
something and you keep having to put it
down because it's so mind-blowingly
speaks to you that's how i felt about
this novel and the characters in it and
rebecca felt the same way and
this sort of fierceness in her and
passion and intensity of her pitch to me
was so
intoxicating
um
and i was just
intoxicated by it um and i thought abs
this is these are the kind of artists i
want to work with you know the fire in
the belly uh that's when it's
at its most exciting you know when
you're joined by sort of comrades with
that fire and i just thought i just left
at that opportunity and you know
it's it's really rare that
you read
uh
portraits of women and especially women
of color of such complexity and
ambiguity and nuance you know
uh both of them i'm sort of repelled and
attracted in equal measures
and you know that's how we feel about
humans in nature you know and you really
see it reflected in in
work and scripts
and that translated from the book into
rebecca's screenplay and it
like vibrates off the screen you know
when you watch it and
it was it was
it was essentially
the novel and rebecca's
beautiful um
allegiance to the work really to to his
work that um
yeah i was going to be involved by any
means necessary
i love it yeah
thank you
andre please all right well good evening
everybody
um
all the reasons that you all have
already said are the same things that
attracted me rebecca i was a fan of hers
for a long time sorry as you like it
many years ago and i saw that too you
saw that play me too
the way she yeah anyway we'll talk about
it
um but that i mean that that her work on
stage you know really really uh floored
me and so when the opportunity to be a
part of this came along it was an easy
yes for me and then also
getting a chance to step into this time
period you know i
got to learn so much that i didn't know
about this time
and you know in addition to discovering
nella's work which i didn't know
anything about i also bumped into a
number of other writers from that time
period who i didn't know about which has
been a real
education and a joy for me so
and then to work with these fabulous
folks
all the bonuses
thank you
um rebecca i want to come back to you
because this is your directorial debut
so congratulations
and you're also an actor so
you get the language of actors and
i wonder if you can talk a little bit
about um some of your choices and going
back to some of the things that you said
earlier
your insistence on this being a black
and white film your insistence on
the specificity of casting
um and the way in which you know you
made your choices um even with lighting
and the cinematography can you talk a
little bit about your process as a
director and what what was important to
you what were you really trying to draw
forth in the film get people to really
pay attention to
sorry that's the next question
i was about to launch in and then you
said what was important to me and i was
like what wasn't important to me i don't
know like the whole
every step of it was so
felt very important on many levels i
the black i'll start with the black and
white it was always
it was always an absolute like there was
no other way to make this movie for me
and it's and it's not about it being
literal it's not like oh we're dealing
with a black and white world therefore
it's black and white it's actually about
our perception of that literalness
because it's a nonsense
nothing is black and white in the world
nothing is black and white on film black
and white is gray it's a thousand shades
of grey
but it brings into light those
categories it makes you think about them
it abstracts it and makes you
see all the binaries that exist in the
film of which there are many
there's black white man woman gay
straight rich poor
it's touched on all of those things
and within all of those things you also
see the limits of it that no one can be
reduced to one definition and invariably
our messy humanity spills out the sides
if we try to
and
like the black and white
element as well as being metaphorical in
that sense
also allowed us to play with shadow and
light and tone
so that nothing is really fixed
and
it was very important to me to cast to
recognizably black women in the roles
not i mean i when i say recognizably i
mean so that you come in at the audience
you have a fixed sense of their identity
you have a fixed sense of their identity
as two black women because from there
the film has a place to destabilize your
fixed idea of that
and i can only do that in black and
white
if you take a scene like in the
beginning in the hotel room when john
the husband is there
like that scene is deliberately
oppressively white the walls are white
the costumes are white there's huge
amounts of light coming in the side of
the window he doesn't see
that they're black because he's dumb or
unobservant it's because in this domain
it's his world he has all the power so
he gets to see what he wants to see
and you are always seeing them as black
you were always in that perspective and
you were always fearing for them and
you're seeing why can't you see what i'm
seeing it it's about context i mean i
love that people watch this film and
some people are like i see this and
other people are like no i see this i'm
absolutely right no i'm absolutely right
and it's like well none of you are
really right because it doesn't look
like the real world so
you know but it forces you to come into
confrontation with that assumption that
idea of perception and context and all
of those things
um the aspect ratio for three is sort of
similar in that
you know again this thematically is
dealing with putting people in boxes
so i literally put them in a box i
wanted them to feel i wanted the film to
feel cloying and constrained and
claustrophobic
you know it's every bit as much about
irene's
experience as it is about claire's it
sort of says that about this is the it's
about a woman who is hiding her racial
identity but the real turn of the whole
story
is that it's actually about the one
who's not hiding her racial identity but
is arguably hiding everything else
about herself
and she is so constrained by her sense
of
how she is meant to be she has put
herself in essence in her own box
she is
so concerned with what kind of
performance i'm speaking i should let
you speak to this but it's
but
you're right
although you know what's funny you've
said so many things about irene and i
never feel defensive but today you said
that she couldn't she can't decorate her
own house because she doesn't know who
she is and i was like wait a minute
i like that couch it was like the first
time i was like
specific because i remember having this
conversation with our production manager
a production designer the great nora
mendez who's fantastic and she she was
sort of telling me about all this
historical detail and saying oh you know
in the 20s everyone had very busy
wallpaper and clashing print on the
couch and everything i was like yeah i
love all that stuff but irene's house
needs to feel not entirely lived in
because she doesn't really know how to
express herself let alone like put
something on the wall so it was about
finding a minimalist way but i know that
ruth was a good friend because right
after she said oh she's talking about
your interior decorating
as irene i was like yeah that that
rubbed me the wrong way too yeah
a la claire
wow well i i love how you use all of the
elements of the film to to bring out
this examination of identity and you
know who people are who they aren't who
they think they are who they think they
aren't i think i said that but um
so i wanted to i wanted to ask tessa and
ruth if you could talk a little bit
about this relationship
that your two characters have
because
you know obviously the film is examining
race but there are so many other things
motherhood um friendship
uh
being a partner
and your
each character's
sort of like internal journey around
those is overlapped by your interactions
with each other so i wonder if you could
talk if you could both talk a little bit
about what that was like working with
each other to explore those all of those
different themes
where do we begin
um
well yeah i suppose
i suppose our performance is sort of
inextricable really aren't they because
they're sort of dependent on one another
um
it's interesting really because
um my job of being sort of this sort of
i don't know
um
charismatic bewitching kind of character
is really was tessa's job to find me
that way do you know what you mean and
because it's interesting really when in
the film
you sort of think
really
irene is the only one who is really
captivated completely and utterly by
this woman you know the way she speaks
about claire is quite hyperbolic and you
know people are sort of you know
attracted to this woman but it's it's
irene that has this sort of
unnatural
obsession with her or attraction
entrance sometimes yes
and that's um
so you're sort of seeing your character
through lenses through prisms through
lenses through prisms and so
um
so that's to me it's sort of
that in itself lends layers to my
performance without me really having to
do anything
um
and i found that really interesting and
i love that idea because i do feel
performance
by its nature is is a deeply ensemble
thing you know it's
you're reliant on
your fellow players you're reliant on
your crew you're reliant on the weather
how you're feeling that day all of this
beautiful alchemy
comes into play and and that kind of is
the scary thing but the beautiful thing
and you know we did we did our prep
beforehand and everything and we managed
to have discussions and such
um but i think you know as with so many
things
um
it's really about exploring what's
happening in that space in between
between action cut
and what you both as individuals doing
your prep and as people bring and that
to me is exciting that's the thrilling
way so i don't know if i can sort of
i don't know how to articulate that so
much you know it's sort of too visceral
okay is that a cop-out no that was good
yeah i i mean just thinking about how
your two characters
they need each other
for it to work in in each scene and even
outside of the scene because you
understand each character based on their
interaction
your interactions with each other
and and i think you know you both
brought that out in your performances in
the film you know we can see there's so
many times where
um
irene has this tensions like you're
holding
all of your thoughts back and like you
said if the the text itself is so rich
with her internal monologue but you
could see it all happening
i wonder if did you
draw on some of that for to
to sort of like build your character or
was there anything that you
that you thought about in your process
of you know thinking about
all those moments
oh
yeah sure um
i i typically am not
like
right a ton in the margins i think
everything that exists in the margins
usually exists inside you or it's not
noteworthy or something but um in this
case there's it's so dense so
when we were playing a scene for example
the first time that they see each other
she writes
you know so specifically about this very
sensual experience in a way
for example
she smells her before she sees her and
she hears her laugh
and so i would reread the passages i had
you know things
nella's exact words charted and rebecca
and i went through you know a pretty
specific process together charting every
single moment of the script because we
shot this in 23 days
it's
not um
yeah that's amazing and then that
deserves a round of applause
so we had very little time
and
we shot
out of sequence of course the first i
think our first day is andre and i in
the car together
um on the way having that sort of you
know argument that is like a
you know a deeply lived-in argument for
them that they've had over many years
thankfully we knew each other so we had
a relationship but still you know so we
shot out of sequence so rebecca and i
worked really precisely
around that but nella's words for me i
kept returning to them i think for some
people that do an adaptation maybe you
sort of depart enough from the source
material you kind of have to let it go
so that you can feel free but for me i
think there was such precision in the
work a because we didn't have much time
because of the aspect ratio if you were
on off your mark
a little bit sometimes you were
literally out of the frame we were
working in a pretty precise way anyway
so
i sort of treated the
the novella in a way
like another piece of music you know
that i was playing these notes inside of
the passages um and i could track that
whether or not the audience could is i
don't have control over that but
certainly for me
like i've only seen the film once when
we saw it in new york and i was like
okay
okay i hope
it looks i'm thinking something and um
and i can trace it to
what nella told me i was thinking for me
i don't know about you all but
there were some moments where i was like
okay i guess that looks like i'm
thinking
um
but yes i returned always to the source
material and as ruth said i think the
performances are so um symbiotic in a
way i mean hopefully performance always
is but especially with this because the
film itself has such restraint there's
such monotony you see her on the same
walk throughout the seasons you see her
in her same chair you get the sense you
know what irene says to brian she says
you're a lot less content with what you
have when she's not here she's talking
about herself
because
when
claire's not around the world lacks
uh electricity and so i i felt free to
have a kind of restraint and performance
uh to to be measured you know to not be
able to hit those extraordinary high
notes all the time because i knew that
she was going to barrel in and do it and
that was cool you know like a
two-man show
but with one man
doing things for the other
speaking of one man
there there is one man
and your role andre is um
is is also
intermingled with these characters um
very intimately and i wonder if you
could talk about
there's a lot of ambiguity there
you know in terms of your your
relationship with each of the characters
can you talk a little bit about what
that was like for you to live in the
ambiguity
performing the ambiguity even
i ain't do it y'all
[Applause]
that's all i got to say i ain't do it
but there are times
[Music]
it's so funny like today we were doing
press and every single woman that came
in was like let me talk to you
the way you looked at that woman in that
living room i know you were up to
something i was like no
uh nah it was fun to play with the
ambiguity because it's ambiguous in the
book it's ambiguous saying rebecca
screenplay and you know i have my
personal feeling i personally feel like
he's a man who loves his wife
has always loved his wife they are maybe
in a moment where they're missing each
other they're not quite connecting in
the way they're used to
and i think claire's arrival ignites
it brings a warmth and heat back into
the house which he enjoys
but i don't think he was he was up to
nothing
that's my story and i'm sticking it
[Laughter]
and he's done folks
[Laughter]
there's another moment between
you and irene that i want to explore
this this moment you talked about um you
know being able to go back into the
literature and into that time period but
it's really interesting how
a lot of the themes in the film
in this in this text that was written in
1929 they still resonate today you know
that whole conversation about
whether or not
your children
should be exposed to this conversation
about lynching i found so interesting
because of the things that irene is also
grappling with right so there are all of
these
things so how did you to sort of like
work through that scene and how do you
think
how do you think it's relevant also to
some of the things that we're talking
about today
i like i like when you talk about this
i feel the same way that it feels uh
sadly relevant
and and you know it reminds me of
conversations that i have with my
parents when i was growing up
right the whole like this is the talk
yeah yeah yeah and uh
yeah that was one of the things that
really drew me to the park is reading
that scene on the page i was like i know
i know what this is i've been here
before and you know i'm not a parent yet
but
i imagine that there will likely be a
day where i'll be here again
um
and yeah it's sad that that is the case
that she was writing about that in 29
and we're still talking about it today
but um
but i feel like uh i feel like the the
film has a lot to contribute to that
conversation
um
anyway it makes me sad to think about
that scene to be honest with you but uh
but i'm i'm
eager to hear what you think tt what you
think
well i think
i we were so excited to shoot that scene
remember it was like a
yeah
i think a lot of things because you know
irene has this sort of moral high ground
in terms of being
a dutiful member of
the black community
and i think her
resistance to talk about the quote race
problem
means that she's actually disconnected
from a huge part of the black experience
in this country which is to acknowledge
that our bodies are not safe
and her resistance to
helping her children understand that
also to make them more safe
is really
interesting you know it's another way in
which she passes in a way
she's she's available to her blackness
in some very specific ways she's even
available to sit and talk to allow
blackness to be um
fetishized with her friend hugh you know
but she cannot talk about the real
experience of being black in this
country and i think you know i think
it's really easy to imagine that you'd
always be on the right side of history
and i really loved that
this
work required me to interrogate that in
self you know to look back at
other times and think about how i would
have shown up in them
you know because we're we exist in a
time now that we'll people will look
back on and say how did you show up
um and so i really like that it's really
easy to sort of put things in the past
and i loved that there was such
modernity to this conversation i don't
love it because it's saddening it's
angering but i like that we have to we
have to re-engage with these things
um we can't allow them i think so often
particularly with narratives about
around race in hollywood it sort of
packs it up neatly and goes like there
were some bad people
and then there were some great people
that were fighting and i know who i am
and um
do you
like
do we
or how can we be sure
um and so i liked that and then also i
love that it's a very domestic fight in
some ways because they also are fighting
about not what they're fighting about
you know he thinks he's having a
conversation about race and how to raise
their sons and she's
having a whole other conversation and
that happens so often sometimes in
relationships where you're not really
fighting about the thing you're fighting
about you're fighting about all the
other stuff underneath and that i
thought there was such richness
which was also exciting because so often
we can place things into one thing and
particularly
in terms of the black experience we
don't get to also have the thing be
about relationships and all that murky
territory you know
yeah
there's so many things yes thank you
so i think we are at about time um but i
just wonder just rebecca to give you the
last word
um
if you can just
say a little bit more about why
this story still resonates
written in 1929 and we're still able to
you know sadly yes
draw these conclusions on so many
different levels but you know why does
it why do you think that it is
resonating so loudly this conversation
about passing race
relationships and
who we are just how we show up
i think sort of crudely speaking i think
that
this sort of notion of how free we are
to form an identity
will always be
relevant
because
whoever we are we all go through this
thing of
the tension between the story that we
tell the world about ourselves and
the one that the world tells us
about ourselves and even beyond that
we go through this problem of i think i
ought to be this sort of person like how
much of the world stuff have we
internalized how much do we know so much
of it it's so much of it and certainly
under systems of racism and patriarchy
and all the rest of it it's like degrees
of this become amplified and
less amplified more amplified in all
sorts of different ways but that is
fundamentally true for all of us
you know we're all we're all negotiating
that
and i
don't think that goes away so
i think something that forces you to
think about that
is
important
and i also think that the film i hope
that the film it's my intention that the
film
doesn't do much work for you
you know it's
whatever you show up with whatever
aspects of your identity you're carrying
when you interact with the film that is
going to inform your experience of it
and
it's deliberately silent
because it was the only way that i could
think of amongst a couple of others but
it was the most significant way that i
could think of of signaling you
i'm not going to tell you what to feel
you've got to lean in and do the work
and think about this
because
you'll get more out of it that way if
you just sit back and excuse the pun
take it at face value
you're only going to see the surface and
you're going to think oh well this is
just a film where nothing really happens
but if you apply yourself and lean think
think and work
there's an awful lot of richness there's
more richness than i can even tell you
because you're all going to have a
million different interpretations of it
you know there are some of you that are
going to think it's all about
repressed homosexuality there are going
to be some of you that think it's all
about adultery there are going to be
some of you that think it's all about
internalized self-hatred that's borne
out of racism and the patriarchy and god
knows what else
they're all true
and they're all meaningful and the fact
that two of you might have a very strong
opinion and then get into a conversation
from both ends of that
means that
you're
entertaining nuance
and
thinking about the gray areas
thank you
well said
um thank you so much rebecca tessa ruth
andre for your work for your creativity
for your courage in making this film
the the production team creative team
cast director writer of passing everyone
thank you so much everybody for coming
thank you
[Music]
you